شكرا للزميل نايف اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل
خير اعزائي المشاهدين تتواصلوا الاشتباكات
والمواجهات في السودان لليوم السابع على
التوالي وسط غموض حول حقيقه ما يجري على
الارض وتضارب البيانات الصادره سواء عن
الجيش السوداني ام من قوات الدعم السريع
اما احدث الانباء الوارده من الخرطوم
فتفيد الان بانسحاب قوات الدعم السريع من
محيط شركه جياد جنوب غرب الخرطوم
تغطيتنا للاحداث في السودان مستمره اهلا
بكم في ساعه جديده من التغطيه
[موسيقى]
دخان المعارك يتواصل صعوده من مقر القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني مع استمرار المعارك
في محيط المقر
للمقر اهميه مركزيه فهو يقع وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم ويتكون من عده مباني تدار من
خلالها الجهات العسكريه والامنيه في
السودان هذه الاهميه سبب تركز القتال بشكل
كبير حول مقر القياده ففيه مباني قياده كل
من القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه وقياده
الاستخبارات العسكريه ووزاره الدفاع كما
يضم المقر ايضا عده مباني مهمه منها مبنى
المخابرات يوم الخميس شهد احتدام المعارك
حول القياده العامه وخاصه في شارع المطار
القريب من المنطقه مع تواصل معارك الكر
والفر وتراوح القتال بين تصعيد وتهدئه
غربا من هذا المقر جرت اشتباكات في محيط
القصر الجمهوري وسط العاصمه السودانيه
وتحدثت وسائل اعلام محليه عن تكثيف قوات
الدعم السريع انت شارها بمدينه الخرطوم
بحري وتحديدا في حله حمد المطله على القصر
الرئاسي على الجانب الاخر من النيل الازرق
ومع اقتراب المعارك من اتمام اسبوعها
الاول يستمر تضارب المعلومات وظهور
تصريحات واخرى مضاده بين طرفي النزاع في
السودان دون اتضاح الصوره بشكل اكبر
وهذه اعزائي المشاهدين مشاهد تردنا الان
الانتشار وحدات من الجيش السوداني في عدد
من شوارع الخرطوم اذا هذه المشاهد تردنا
الان الانتشار
قوات من الجيش السوداني في
بعض شوارع الخرطوم لا ندري تحديدا اسماء
هذه الشوارع ولكن كما
تردنا بالطبع لا نستطيع ان نتاكد اسم هذا
الاسماء الشوارع ولكن هذه الصور تردنا
لانتشار قوات من الجيش السوداني في عدد من
شوارع
الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
مشكله المويه الحقيقه مشكله كبيره الناس
ما لاقيه يعني حتى الموت الصحفي المحلات
التجاريه
استخدموا الاباء الجوفيه والمعاناه كبيره
جدا
وهي مياه برضو مش صالحه للشرب غدر ما هي
ممكن يتم استخدامك
الى مدينه مروي الان ينضم الي من هناك
مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني واخر
التطورات وهل يمكن التاكيد تماما ان مدينه
مروي ومطارها وسدها هي تحت سيطره الجيش
السوداني
صباح اليوم في تصريحات بها العربيه
سالناه سؤالا مباشرا هل باتت قوات الدعم
الشريعه الان تماما خارج دون المحليه
والولايه اكد ان السيطره مستمره وان قوات
الدعم الفريق خارج حدود مروي هذه
التاكيدات تاتي غازات خروج قوات الدعم
السريع
وارغام الجيش بحسب بيانه الاخير لهذه
القوات بالخروج من القاعده والمطار
والاتجاه جنوبا
الجو طيران الجو السوداني مع طبقي القوه
التي خرجت من مطار مروي خلال الايام
الماضيه الان هنالك وجود
وحاضر
لوحدات للجيش السوداني في مطار منوي تعمل
على حراقه المطار تعمل على تامين المطار
الفرقه التاسع عشر مشاه حسب ما اكدت بانها
ستظهر
تعمل على تامين كل المنشاتيه في حدود
مسؤوليتها لتامين المرافق في هذه المنطقه
الان الجيش يؤكد بانه وسط السيطره وان
الامور الان تحت سيطرته وتمضي نحو
الاستقرار النزار قلت انه وحدات الدعم
السريع باتت خارج مرعي ولكن الى اين
انسحبت تحديدا هل يمكن معرفه الى اي
ولايات او مدن اخرى انسحبت
شهود عيان اكدوا
تدخلت طائرات الحربيه بان قوات الدعم
السريع من مروي التي توجد في الجزء
الشمالي من السودان اتجهت جنوبا
الخرطوم تحديدا الى الطريق الذي يربط بين
ام درمان المدينه الثانيه في الخرطوم وبين
مدينه مروي هذه الجهات وهذه الطرق تاخذك
مباشره من مروي ومن مدن شمال السودان الى
ام درمان والى الطريق منه يمكن ان يعبر بك
نحو الصحراء ومنها الى دارفور وايضا يمكن
ان يعبر بك نحو ولايه نهر النيل في هذه
اتجهت قوات الدعم السريع ويبدو ان التعامل
الطيران مع اكثر من 120 سياره واليه تتبع
للدعم السريع
واحضاف الضرر في عشرات منها احدث في مسار
الطريق وخللا في الطريقه التي خرجت بها
قوات الدعم السريع مما جعلها تتفرق وتتجه
في مسارات مختلفه نزار هل يؤكد لك
المسؤولون الذين تتكلم معهم في الجيش
السوداني ان قوات الدعم السريع لن تعاود
مهاجمه مروي ام لا الامور غير واضحه يعني
الحرب سجال
[موسيقى]
والاستعدادات الموضوعه الان نحن الان كما
تعلم
السودان في حاله حرب والقوات المسلحه في
كل وحداتها الان
قطعت درجه الاستعداد الى نسبه 100% كذلك
هي ضمن المناطق التي شهدت سجالا وشهدت
معارك وشهدت اشتباكات كثيفه بينها وبين
قوات الدعم السريع درجه الاستعداد طالما
انها حاضره وطالما انها مستمره يعني ان كل
التوقعات حاضره على ارض الميدان حالات
الكر والفرح حالات التمركز لكن ما نراه
وما نشاهده بان الجيش الان له من
الامكانيات وله من العتاد وله من المدفعيه
وله من الطيران كما يؤكد هو بانه قادر على
التعامل مع اي تطورات تقرا وتحدث في اي
مرحله من مراحل هذه الحرب طيب نزار ابقى
معي اليك بعد قليل ولكن ساعرض الان على
المشاهدين هذه الصور التي نشرتها قوات
الدعم السريع منذ قليل الاستيلاء عناصرها
على مدرعات للجيش السوداني في شارع مدني
منذ حوالي الساعتين كانت قوات الدعم
السريع قد اعلنت سيطرتها على شارع مدني
وسط الخرطوم
بعد ان قامت بالتسلل كما قيل من شارع
الستين باتجاه
شارع مدني واستولت على هذا الشارع هذه صور
تعرضها قوات الدعم السريع
لسيطره قوتها على مدرعات للجيش
السوداني حسب
ترد يعني لا نستطيع تاكيد او نفي هذه
الصور ولكن نعرضها عليكم كما هي اذا قوات
الدعم السريع تقول انها سيطرت على مدرعات
للجيش السوداني في شارع مدني بعد ان احكمت
السيطره على هذا
الشارع اعود الى مراسل العربيه في مدينه
مروي نزار بقداوي نزار حجم الاضرار في
مطار مروي نتيجه الاشتباكات كيف يمكن وصفه
وهل تسنى لك يعني معرفه حجم الاضرار او
الاطلاع على حجم الاضرار
نعم قبل ذلك يعني نريد ان نعدل بعض
المعلومات وبعض التصريحات وبعض الملامح
والاشارات التي تصدر من الصور الصور التي
تعرض انا بعيد بعض الشيء لكن الحديث عن
الطريق مدني وسط الخرطوم مدني هذا الطريق
ليس وسط الخرطوم وانما يربط بين مدينه
الخرطوم وولايه الجزيره يتجه من العاصمه
جنوبا في اتجاه ولايات الجزيره وولايه
سنار وولايات اخرى منها الى شرق السودان
وليس وسط العاصمه الخرطوم هذا فقط للتصحيح
بان الطريق مدني ليس داخل الخرطوم وانما
خارج الخرطوم في الطريق هو طريق مدني
الخرطوم يربط بين ولايه الخرطوم وولايه
الجزيره وقوات الدعم السريع في هذا الطريق
خارج حدود ولايه القرطبي
بالعوده الى سؤالي
نعم بالعوده الى السؤال الاضرار التي
لاحظناها يوم الامس ان كنت تتابع حسب
الصور الحصريه التي قلنا فيها يوم الامس
حتى الضرر كاننا واضحا وكان كبيرا داخل
قاعده مروي العسكريه الجويه وداخل المطار
اليات كثيفه عشرات الاليات تضررت هنالك
مخزن شاهدناه يوم الامس كانوا يضم سيارات
عديده تقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطيران
المدني وللطيران العسكري هذه السيارات
احترقت بالكامل ولم يتبقى منها سوى الرماد
والحديد المحترق
الضرر ايضا لاحقه بالقسمه المعني بتقديم
خدمات الدفاع المدني
في عدد من المرافق الحيويه في المطار
المكاتب الاداريه المكاتب التي تقدم
الخدمات للسلام الجويه ارضيه المطار ايضا
تضررت والضرر الاخر هو وجود اجسام غير
منفجره ما زالت على ارضيه المطار بعد
الطائرات ايضا احترقت كل هذه اللائحه من
الضرر تستدعي عملا كثيفا وهذا العمل بدا
بالفعل مساء الامس من قبل سلاح المهندسين
التابع للجيش هذا السلاح من به ان يقوم
بتنظيف الارضيه وتنظيف المقر والوحدات
داخل القاعده والمطار وحتى يرفع التقرير
بان المطار بارضيته بمنشاته بابراجه مهيئه
تماما حتى يعود للعمل والا خطر الان من
انفجار اي جسم تم تركه او خلف نتيجه هذه
الاشتباكات التي دارت روحاها خلال الايام
الماضيه في مطار مراوي الذي كان مسرحا
وارضيه لعمليات عسكريه مستمره
الان بالنسبه الى الشؤون الحياتيه بالنسبه
الى موضوع الكهرباء والماء والانترنت هل
من الممكن ان تعطينا اطلاله على مجريات
هذه الامور في في بتعرف الاوضاع في
الخرطوم يعني كارثيه فيما خاص موضوع
الكهرباء المشافي
شح المياه وصول المساعدات ماذا عن مروي
نزار
لاخذ جوله في محيط المحيط الاجتماعي
والمدني والخدمي في مروي تحديدا لناخذ
بدوله تبدا بمحطات الوقود البنزين الجاز
يوم الامس كان هنالك اصطفاف في محطات
الوقود بواقع ان هذه المحطات التي تقدم
خدمه الوقود كانت قد توقفت بصوره اجباريه
اصحاب هذه
الطلمبات واصحاب هذه هي المستودعات تخوفوا
من ان تمتد اثار الضرب والحريق الى هذه
المستودعات وبالتالي تشكل خطر على حياه
المواطنين وغلقت هذه المحطات للنقود لكن
يوم الامس بدات في العمل راينا صفوف لكن
هذه صفوف يبدو انها ليست
بالقدر الذي يمكن ان نقول بانها ظاهره
للاصطفاه بقدر ما هي حرص من المواطنين على
التزود بالوقود خاصه وانهم الان دخلوا في
اجازه العيد ويحتاجون الى التنقل من مدينه
الى مدينه اما خدمات المياه فهي مت تحديدا
في مروي وفي كريمه وفي قرى كريمه وقرى
مروي وفي دنقله وفي مختلف المناطق
الكهرباء ايضا متوفره تقطع بعض الشيء لكن
تعود بسرعه بواقع الساعه الى نصف ساعه
قطوعات الكهرباء خدمات الانترنت موجوده
الضعيفه بعض الشيء لبعض الشركات لكنها
متوفره المواطنون الان يتواصلون عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي المناحي المتعلقه
بخدمات الغذاء وتقديم الدعم الدوائي لم
نلحظ اي ندره في الدواء في هذه المنطقه
لان حجم الاشتباكات وحجم الضرر كان فقط
يتعلق بالاليات وبالعتاد العسكري في
القاعده ولم يوصيب المواطنون بنسبه تجعل
منهم في طريق ممتد نحو المستشفيات
والمرافق الصحيه
ودخول عطور صحيه واسعاف والطبيب احمر او
هلال احمر هذه الامور تجنبها المواطنين
واصبحوا بملئا عنها لانهم لم يكونوا جزءا
من هذه الوضعيه التي نعيشها الان في
الخرطوم الامور الان مستقره الحياه بدات
الى طبيعتها شيئا فشيئا لكن يظل الترقب
ويظل التوتر حاضرا طالما ان البلاد في
مرحله حرب هذه الكلمه بان السودان في
مرحله حرب حتى مروي الامن الان يتخوف
كثيرون هنا في مروي من ان تعاد ذات
اللحظات المؤلمه واللحظات السوداء التي
عاشتها في اي لحظه من اللحظات لكنهم
يؤمنون في ظل انتشار القوات المسلحه وجود
العتاد العسكري والمدفعيه الثقيله
الموجوده في هذه المنطقه بان تكون هذه
المنطقه بملئا عن اي صراع او اشتباك خلال
الايام المقبله
من المناطق والولايات يعني حتى مدينه
الخرطوم يعني شهدت نزوحا كثيفا على الاقل
في مناطق داخليه في نزوح خارجي يعني من
ولايات
في السودان الى تشاد هل سجلت حركه نزوح
باتجاه مروي او من مروي ام لا الامور يعني
فيما يتعلق بالنزوح مستقره ما في هذه
الظاهره فيما راوي سواء من او الى مروي
عضو مباشره الى مروي الى منازلهم الى
مساكنهم عدد من المنازل تاثرت لان عدد من
الشظايا وقعت في البيوت نعم ان بعض
الدانات كانت على مقربه من منازل
المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
لم يصاب المواطنون باذى كبير فقط لاصابات
تم التعامل معها الان حاله الاستقرار تبدو
هي المسيطر على المشهد
والهدوء الحذر ايضا يبدو مسيطرا على
المشهد ونلخص ونقول بان السودان في حاله
حرب وكل سيناريو يمكن ان يتكرر طالما انه
حدث قبل ذلك من مدينه مروي مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي شكرا جزيلا لك نزار على كل
هذه المتابعه من مدينه مرو
اعزائي المشاهدين كاميرا العربيه كانت اول
وسيله اعلاميه تتمكن من تصوير قاعده الدعم
السريع في منطقه جبل سركاب شمال ام درمان
وكانت قوات الجيش السوداني قد سيطرت على
القاعده قبل ايام
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
صداقه العقدين بين البرهان واحمدتي لن
تنتصر على خلافهما على السلطه تصدعات عده
بدات منذ عام 2021
زادها اتساعا قرار دمج قوات الدعم السريع
بالجيش ما دفع بالعلاقه بينهما الى
الانهيار
20 عاما قضاياها رفيقيدر بن وسلاح خندق
واحد جمع الضابطين اللذين عمل جنبا الى
جنب في ميادين القتال قبل ان يخرق صمت
المماطله بالاتفاق رصاص اوقع وحده الصف
وارهق صداقه امتدت لعقدين من الزمن
ابن بادر بسيط
نجاه في حوامل السودان كل منهما يتحذر من
مدرسه قتاليه مغيره صرامه عسكريه وتمرس
بمطارده الحركات المسلحه جمعت بينهما
ضرورات مرحليه تتقاطع مع ظروف حرب دارفور
عام 2003 فهناك كان اللقاء الاول بين عبد
الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان دقلو حينها
كان البرهان ضابطا بسلاح المشاه في مقاد
احمدتي عشرات المسلحين لحمايه الاهالي
وقوافل لتجارتهم
تقاسم مهامه وذخيره صعدت بعدها العلاقه
تدريجيا وان عن بعد قبل ان يدور الزمن
ويعيدهما لصداره المشهد عام 2019
تحالف عسكري سياسي هذه المره بهدف اسقاط
حكم البشير تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ليمتطيا معا صهوه فتره انتقاليه كان يؤمل
منها قياده البلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
مجلس عسكري له اخر عرف بمجلس السياده
الانتقالي تراسهما تباعا البرهان منتقيا
في كل مره صديقه للنيابه عنه
هذه العلاقه ظلت خاليه من التشويش لحين
اصطدامها بحائط رمي المسؤوليه عن فض
اعتصام القياده عام 2019
فبرزت شروخ داخل المكون العسكري تلملمت
على الاقل ظاهريا حمدتي اي دام وصف
بانقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر ثم
تاسف عنه وامتعض من اعاده قائد الجيش
لعناصر النظام السابق للسلطه واتسعت
الفجوه اكثر مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
والخلاف على جداول الزمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه خلاف عجزت
مسيره الشراكه الطويله عن احتوائه وبين
العشاء الاول في دارفور والعشاء الاخير في
الخرطومه ذابت القضيه مع محاوله الاسراع
بتذويب الدعم السريع داخل الجيش بصفه
نهائيه
مع الان من دارفور لمزيد من المتابعه
الصحفيه السودانيه صالح ابو علامه السيد
صالح اهلا وسهلا بك اولا سوره المشهد من
دارفور كيف تبدو لك وهل الامور هادئه
تماما ام ان النار تحت الرماد كما يقال
اهلا وسهلا ومرحبا بك طالب ومرحبا
بالعربيه الحدث
في باسور يسوده
الهدوء الحذر في ولايه دارفور الخمس وبين
متابعين انه اكثر ولايتين تضررت خلال
الايام الماضيه هي جنوب دير وشمال دارفور
خلال الفتره الماضيه ان وصل الى مستشفيات
كل من جنوب دارفور وشمال دارفور في جنوب
دارفور حالات القتل بين المديين وصلت الى
و46 قتيل في الفاشل وفي بقيه الولايات
هنالك قتلها جمله
وصل الى 100 قتيل وايضا اكثر من 100 جريح
خلال الاحداث الماضيه اخر قتيل سقط الليله
البارحه في شمال دارفور بعد الهدنه
المعلنه وايضا في شمال دارفور نجمه الامن
الخاصه بولايه شمال دارفور وضعت اتفاق بين
الجيش والدعم السريع لان يسمح لجنه مكونه
من
الامنيه والقيادات الشعبيه
بالوصول للجثث وايضا لفتح الممرات الامنه
لوصول الجرحى
للمنتجات حتى الان في شمال دارفور هذه
المدنه تسير بصوره جيده
لكن النار الرمادي يمكن ان تنفجر الاوضاع
في اي وقت حتى في الولايات الاخرى خلاف
جنوب دارفور وشمال دارفور لجهه ان دارفور
هشه امنيا في الفترات الماضيه وهذه
الاحداث احدثت شخص كبير جدا في المجتمع في
حالات النهب والسلب اصبحت كبيره جدا والان
غير مستتب داخل المدن في اقليم دارفور
ايضا خلفت احداث نعم
صالح
كمان لنعطي فكره للمشاهدين يعني الاوضاع
مثلا مساله الاوضاع المعيشيه الامور
الحياتيه كهرباء ماء انترنت مثلا في
الخرطوم الاوضاع كارثيه في ولايه دارفور
ماذا يمكن ان نقول عن موضوع الكهرباء وعن
موضوع
هل يعني متوفره في جميع الولايات ام لا
الامور مختلفه من ولايه الى اخرى
صالحه هل تسمعني
[موسيقى]
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنانين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق رصاصه الاولى
طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات
بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل التنافس بينهما
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت
الالات العسكريه المتنافسه تستعد للقتال
تدفقت القوات بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش
المتنافسه في جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم
بدايه الخلاف وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق
حمد المتمثل باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا
للنظام السابق فيما بدات المخابرات
العسكريه بقياده البرهان في اخبار
المسؤولين الاجانب بان تحاول سرا استيراد
طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من تركيا لتعزيز
قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى بين افراد الجيش
والدعم السريع الذين تعاملك قوتين
متنافستين وليس منسجمتين ضمن نفس الدوله
لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم الخلاف اكثر محاوله
الاتفاق على دمج القوتين في جيش واحد
خصوصا ان هذه العمليه ستخرج حمدتي الخاسره
الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوث الامريكي حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
مع من باريس الاهلي مزيد من المتابعه
الكاتب السودانيه المتخصص بالشؤون
الافريقيه محمد تورشين استاذ محمد اهلا
وسهلا بك سؤال يطرح نفسه تعرف يعني ما
زالت الاسئله اكثر من الاجوبه مع دخول
يعني هذه الحرب او هذه المواجهات الاسبوع
اسبوع اسبوعها الاول
الان الاسبوع الثاني سيبدا لماذا السؤال
يعني المنطقي لماذا سقطت جميع الهدن او
الهدنات سميها ما شئت لماذا لم تصمت اي من
الهدن وهل الامور وصلت الى نقطه لا عوده
بين الطرفين والامر متروك الى الميدان الى
الرصاص وليس لاي مبادره او حتى هن
في البدايه التحيه لك ولكل الساده
المشاهدين الكرام
للاسف الشديد يمكن ان نقوله بالفم المليء
وبكل ثقه فان الاوضاع بين الجنابين وصلت
الى مرحله اللا عوده وذلك
ظهر جليا وكنا نثق في ذلك عندما اندلعت
هذه المواجهات لانه في الاصل هذا الصراع
هو صراع حول السلطه والنفوس فبالتالي هو
اذا مضت عمليه دمج قوه الدعم السريع في
الجيش الخاطر الاكبر هو محمد حمدان لماذا
لانه لا يستوفي في شروط العمل في المؤسسه
العسكريه جنرال بنفس الرتبه وبنفس
المخصصات فضلا عن ذلك كل المؤسسات
والامبراطوريه الاقتصاديه الضخمه التي
اسسها محمد حمدان مؤخرا عقب سقوط نظام عمر
البشير وكذلك نتيجه لالقاء الماده الخامسه
من قانون الدعم السريع الذي اتحد له حريه
الحركه حريه التسليح والتسلح عقد صفقات
الناس بشبكه من العلاقات اقليميه والدوليه
وكذلك المدفعيه والمدرعات وما الى ذلك الا
ان في الجانب الاخر هو الدعم السريع تتميز
بسهوله الحرقه والرشاقه وكذلك انتشار
عناصر كبيره جدا ربما العناصر التي الان
منتشره في الخرطوم فوق 50,000 هذه كلها
عوامل جعلت من معطيات المعركه لا يستطيع
احد التفهم بها في ظل
اليس اليس تسطيحا لقراءه ما يجري في
السودان القول ان ما يجري هو مجرد خلاف
شخصي على السلطه بين جنريلين لا الامر
اكثر تشابك وتعقيد وفي قوى ربما خارجيه
دفعت بهذا الاتجاه يعني ان من فتح هذه
الحرب لا يريد لها ان تنتهي بيوم او يومين
او اسبوع هذه الحرب فتحت لتبقى
المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا او لا يمكن
قراءتها حل من الاحوال عن تداعيات ازمه
المنطقه بشكل عام او تداعيات الثوره
الربيع العربي في المشهد في السودان
المعقد
وهذا تاثير وارتباط بالمحيط الاقليمي
الامر الذي يعطي يؤكد بان هذه الحرب كما
تفضلت بالذكر ان هنالك جهاد ربما ادركت
مؤخرا بان مسار التغيير في السودان ربما
يكون هو هاجس يربط المشهد المشهد بشكل عام
المنطقه بشكل اشمل فبالتالي ينبغي ان يتم
تغيير هذا المسار بشكل او باخر فانا اؤكد
لك ان في كلا الحالتين الخاصره الاكبر هو
الشعب السوداني والشباب والقطاعات الوازعه
التي تؤمن تكون هنالك حكومه ومنتخبه تمثل
اراده الشعب الفتره الانتقاليه اه باعتبار
انه اذا استطعت انه يحقق الدعوه السريعه
انتصار هذه مرضيه ضعيفه جدا لكن لا يمكن
ابعاده ستتحول الى البلاد الى واقع يعني
لا يدعى عليها البلاد الى
امبراطوريه وسريع اذا انتظر الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان سيعزز نفوزه في محاوله
السيطره على البلاد وربما تاتي بعض
العناصر العناصر النظام تسيطر على المشهد
فبالتالي في كلا الحالتين المعادله معقده
جدا لكن انا اتحدث على ضروره ان يتم
انتصار من قبل القوات المسلحه واعاده
هيكله المؤسسه العسكريه
لازم اللجنه الامنيه لعمر البشر هل تعتقد
ان من فتح هذه الحرب يريد لطرف ان يحقق
نصرا ساحقا على الطرف الاخر ام لا يعني
يريد لهذه الحرب ان تبقى سجالا ونكون امام
سيناريو مثل السيناريو الليبي بمعنى ان كل
طرف يسيطر على منطقه على اجزاء من السودان
وتبقى الامور على ما هي عليه كما هي
الامور مثلا في ليبيا على سبيل المثال
يعني العاصمه وعدد من المدن مع فريق
وبنغازي وعدد من المدن الاخرى في ليبيا مع
فريق اخر وهكذا دواليك الى اي مدى هذا
السينا ريو تعتقد انه سيناريو قائم ويمكن
ان نشهده في الاشهر المقبله في السودان
هو كما تفضلت بالذكر انه انه هذا
السيناريو حتى السيناريو الليبي لم يكن
مخطط في المدى انت تعيش ليبيا في حاله من
الفوضى الاقراء في
فيما كانوا كل طرف سواء كان
البنغازي طرابلس تعتقد بانها من السهل جدا
القضاء على الطرف الاخر وتحقيق نصر ساحق
في فتره وجيزه لكن او نتيجه لتغير
المعطيات والحلفاء في الحرب الليبيه جعلت
المشهد ممتاز فانا في تقدير الان ايضا في
الحاله السودانيه بالرغم ان الطرفين حتى
الان لا توجد مؤشرات فعليه على على انتظار
طرف على اخر بالرغم ان البيانات كل طرف
انه هو المنتظر لكن انا لا اثق في هذه
البيانات كثيرا لاعتبارات كثيره انا في
تقدير الان فعليا فعليا اذا اذا الان
تحدثنا عن اسبوع ولا يوجد طرف فعليا حسب
هذه المعرفه انا اؤكد لك اذا استمرت هذه
الاوضاع في غضون ثلاثه ايام اخرى ولم يحقق
اي طرف انتصار فعلي واقعي وعاده الحياه
الى مجراها نحن سنكون اسوا من السيناريو
الليبي معلوم انها مقسمه الى الى قسمين
لكن السودان الان يمكن ان تتدخل العديد من
القوه نتيجه لان السودان دوله قنيه
بالسنوات والموارد فضلا عن ذلك السود
الدوله في افريقيا هنالك ترابط تداخل مع
عدد من دول الاجوار فضلا عن ذلك هنالك
التناحر قبلي عميق جدا في السودان فضلا عن
انتشار السلاح الان العديد من يعني اذا
استمرت هذه المواجهات والحرب ان تتفجر
الصراعات القبليه والعشائريه والجهويه على
كل من باريس الكاتب السوداني المختص
بالشان الافريقي محمد تورشين شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاركه
ننتقل الى هذه الصور الان لانتشار الجيش
او وحدات من الجيش السوداني في الخرطوم
في شوارع بعض احياء الخرطوم لا ندري
تحديدا اسماء هذه الشوارع ولكن تردنا
الصور سريعا
بالطبع نريدها لكم اذا انتشار لوحدات او
عناصر من الجيش السوداني في عدد من شوارع
الخرطوم كان كنا شاهدنا دوريات راجله
للجيش السوداني تجوب بعض شوارع الخرطوم
ولكن بالطبع كان هنالك فيديوهات لقوات
الدعم السريع تنفي ذلك في المقابل وتتحدث
عن انتشار لها ايضا في عدد من شوارع
الخرطوم
على كل المواقع الاستراتيجيه الحيويه على
مستوى الدوله السودانيه
وهذه الصور ايضا كما قلنا في المقابل قوات
الدعم السريع تعلن السيطره على الهيئه
مبدا الهيئه العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون
بالطبع يعني لم نتاكد من هذه من هذه الصور
مع العلم انه يعني الجيش السوداني يسيطر
على مبنى البث يعني في التلفزيون السوداني
ويبث بياناته من مبنى البث القوات الدعم
السريع تنشر فيديوهات تقول انها سيطرت على
الهيئه العامه للاذاعه او على مبنى الهيئه
العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون كما نشاهد يعني
كما منذ بدء هذه المواجهات المعلومات
متضاربه
والبيانات تناقض بعضها البعض على كله
اعزائي المشاهدين اختلط التكبيرات عيد
الفطر في السودان با صوات اطلاق النار منذ
ساعات الفجر الاولى وقد تغير المشهد من
مساجد مقتظه في كل عيد الى اعداد شحيحه
خوفا من القصف المتبادل ما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
تكبيرات تختلط بازيز الرصاص عيد السودان
يبكي اهله باعداد شحيحه في المصليات
يخرجون من المساجد فرادى لا مصلين
يرتادونها كما عهد عيد الفطر فرحته
بازدحامهم
لكن بعضهم لم يابه كثيرا بتلك المعارك
فخرجوا رغما عن الصراع ولبوا نداء السعاده
بمعايده مغلفه باطلاق النيران
عيد لم تكتمل اركانه في السودان كتب على
اهله البقاء في المنازل او الخروج لاقتناص
صلاه بصحبه الاقارب او الاصدقاء والعوده
قبل ان تخطئهم باروده تلك الاشتباكات لا
حول ولا
طرحه مسلوبه الا من امنيه اتحد عليها
السودانيون يرجون فيها ان ينعم بلدهم
بالامن والاستقرار
ان نرجع السودان الاصلي
بالامن والاستقرار يعني ربنا يعم علينا
بالسلام والبركه والخير يعني
الناس وصلوا يعني للاتفاق والناس تعيش في
امني وسلامه
الوضع يتحسن ان شاء الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر هكذا كان السودان على
الاقل منذ سنه لكنه يعيش مشاهد غير مالوفه
يغص بها البلد الذي اعتاد التهافت الى
شوارع تفوح فيها رائحه حلوى العيد ومن ذاك
العام الى هذا العام تكتب حرب الجنرالات
ان تبقي ذكريات العيد الماضي حاضره
بطقوسها في مخيلتهم لا وقعهم المرير اسراء
الصغير العربيه
هذا وقالت مجموعه الازمات الدوليه في بيان
لها ان الاشتباكات الحاليه في السودان قد
تتطور الى حرب اهليه في حال لم يتوقف
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع كما دعت المنظمه البلدان المجاوره
للسودان وكل من لديه علاقه وثيقه مع
البرهان واحمدتي بان يتم التواصل معهما
لايجاد حل مناسب ووقف الاشتباكات بين
القوتين
هذا وثقت مقاطع فيديو متداوله على
الانترنت عمليات سلب ونهب في العاصمه
الخرطوم ونيال باعتبارها ثاني اكبر مدينه
تاثرت بشكل كبير وسجلت اعلى الخسائر على
المستويين المادي والاقتصادي وكذلك ايضا
على مستوى اعداد القتلى
ثم حاله النحو وكسر سمو الكنانه كل
الدكاكين تم نحبوا بصوره مباشره وحرق
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله لا حول ولا قوه
الا بالله
نسال الله السلامه والعافيه نسال الله
يخلق لهم خيرا مما فقدوا عسى الله يخلف
لهم خيرا مما فقدوا
قالت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود انا فريقها
الطبي لا يمكنه ادخال اي امدادات طبيه
اضافيه الى السودان في ظل الاشتباكات
الحاليه محذره من انه ان لم يتغير الوضع
في المنطقه فسيكون هناك المزيد من الخسائر
في الارواح كما اشارت المنظمه في بيان
الله الى ان الامدادات التي تقدمها في
مستشفى الفاشر ستكفي فقط لثلاثه اسابيع
اضافيه في حال عدم ادخال اي امدادات جديده
الى المستشفى
قال وزير الخارجيه الاسباني خوسيه مانويل
الباريس في مؤتمر الصحفي في برلين ان
الطائرات العسكريه الاسبانيه في وضع
الاستعداد وجاهزه لاجلاء حوالي 60 مواطنا
اسبانيا ونحو 20 مدنيا من دول اخرى من
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وسط صراع مسلح
في تلك البلاد
الى ذلك قالت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه انها
على تواصل مستمر مع السلطات السودانيه
لتسهيل عوده مواطنيها عبر المعابر البريه
في السودان دون عوائق واضافت الخارجيه في
بيان النشارته على فيسبوك انها تواصل من
خلال بعثاتها في السودان بذله كافه الجهود
والقيام بالاتصالات اللازمه لمتابعه اوضاع
الجاليه المصريه في البلاد خلال الازمه
والتعاطي السريع معها تبعا للمستجدات
معي من القاهره الان مدير تحرير المدير
التحرير في جريده الاهرام والمختص في
الشان الافريقي محمد ابو الفضل الاستاذ
محمد اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه هل من قرار
نهائي من قبل السلطات المصريه باجلاء جميع
الرعايه
المصريين من السودان
وهل هذه مساله بسيطه ام لا هذه مساله
معقده جدا وتاخذ وقتا
بالطبع يعني هناك اهتمام مصري بعوده
الرعايه المصريه لكن هي المساله اني مش
عدد هؤلاء ليس قليلا يعني بعض التقديرات
تقول انها اكثر من عشره الاف وبعد
التقديرات تقول ان هناك ارقام مضاعفه لمصر
خبره كبيره في مساله املاء الرعايه نحن
نذكر عندما اندلعت الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه كانت مصر سباقه في مساله عوده
المصريين الموجودين في اوكرانيا ربما كان
هناك بضعه الاف وكان هناك سرعه في التحرك
في هذه المساله اليوم الوضع اكثر تعقيدا
في السودان وبالتالي مساله عوده الرعايه
ليس بالبساطه كما يتصورها البعض المجرد ان
مصر والسودان بلدان متجاوران وان هناك
حدود طويله ومشتركه وان هناك خط بري معروف
بان يربط بين جنوب مصر وشمال السودان اسمه
قسطل ابو سمبل لكن المسافه بين قسط وادي
حلفا المسافه بين قصر وادي حلف تصل الى
حوالي 300 كيلو متر ومن وادي حلف الى تصل
الى حوالي 700 كيلو متر وهذه مسافه كبيره
وشاسعه المساء في شمال السودان يكاد يكون
هادئا الى حد كبير لكن المشكله في الخرطوم
من والى الخرطوم في وصوله هؤلاء الى
الحدود المصريه اعتقد ان ما لم يكن هناك
وقف تام وتوفير ممرات امنه واخف وقف
المساله اطلاق النار وتوفير ممرات امنه
سيكون من الصعوبه عوده هؤلاء المثل انا
اخشى ما اخشاه ان يكون هناك رغبه دوليه من
استنزاف الطرفين في هذه المعركه المحتدمه
حتى يتسنى للقوات الدوليه فرض امر واقع او
حل او تصورات محدده عمليه الاستنزاف
الجاريه تفسرها عند كل طرف يعتقد انه لديه
قدره على حسم المعركه خلال فتره وجيزه نحن
امام مشهد معقد بيانات وبينات مضاده لا
نستطيع تحديد الخريطه ربما يكون هناك تفوق
نسبي لقوات الجيش السوداني لكن في المقابل
هناك مساحه من الحركه تستطيع ان تتحرك من
خلالها قوات الدعم السريع لحسب بعض الامور
كما شاهدنا فيما يتعلق ببعض الطرق او
المفاصل الواصله من الخرطوم والولايات
اخرى كل هذه المشاهد بتعقد المهمه المصريه
بل المهمه الدوليه ايضا هناك دول كثيره
تريد اجلاء رعيها لكنها لا تريد ولا ولا
تعرف كيف يتم ادلاء هذه المساله في ظل
استمرار اطلاق النار بين الطرفين طيب
استاذ محمد
استطرادا لما تقول هل يفتح هذا الصراع في
السودان الباب على مصراعيه لشهيه الدول
الخارجيه للتدخل اكثر فاكثر في السودان مع
ما يعنيه كل ذلك
هناك تدخل فعلي اقليمي ودولي في السودان
ربما لم تتواصل لنا مشاهد محدده او معطيات
محدده حول هذا التدخل لكن كل طرف لديه
علاقات وثيقه اقليميه ودوليه محدده وهذا
يفسر لنا لماذا الموقف الاقليمي والدولي
في قدر من السيوله وعدم الحسب الى حد كبير
كل يعني طرف علاقاته بتمكنه بعدم اتخاذ
موقف محدد ايضا كما ذكرت ان اشعر بان هناك
رغبه في الاستنزاف الطرفين حتى يتم فرد
امر واقع او فرض تصورات من قبل المجتمع
الدولي محدده في ظل حاله التوازن الكبيره
بين الطرفين وامتلاك كلاهما لقوات محدده
يستطيع بها ان يوجه بها ضربات للطرف الاخر
في لحظات معينه يكون من الصعوبه هنا يعني
جمعهما للتفاوض او للتفاهم وما الى ذلك
الطريق وصل الى خط لا رجعه ولا عوده فيه
بين القياديين البرهان وحمدتي اعت يعني كل
المؤشرات تقول مساله جلوزهما معا او
تفاهمها او تفاهم بينهما مساله في غايه
الصعوبه لم يتفهمها في وقت الهدوء ووقت ان
كان حليفين ومتضامنين ايضا فما بالنا اذا
كانت الامور بقت او دخلت في مسار اكثر
تعقيدا الان كل المؤشرات تقول ان نحن امام
ثلاث او اربع او خمسه ايام ربما تكون من
المعارك المستمره
بعدها تتضح الصوره اذا استمرت هذه المعارك
وما تكبده من خسائر بشريه للشعب السوداني
وهو المتضرر اكبر من هذه المساله سيكون
الموقف الدولي عليه ان يتدخل بشكل حاسم
وبشكل سريع بفرض تصور محدد على الطرفين قد
ينتهي بفوز احدهما قد ينتهي
بخسارتهما معا يعني حتى الان الامور يصعب
التوقع بها لكن في كل الاحوال
الايام المقبله ستكون في حسب الموقف
العسكري على الارض استاذ محمد
هل التقييم المصري لمجريات المواجهات
الجاريه الان ينبي بان القاهره تتحضر لحرب
طويله جدا في السودان مع ما يعنيه كل ذلك
خبره مصر في التعامل مع ليبيا تفرض عليها
التحضر لهذا السيناريو وربما يكون
السيناريو السودان ابشع من ليبيا يعني كما
ذكر يعني ضيفكم قبل قليل ان السودان به
حركات مسلحه وبتداخلات قباليه وتداخلات
اجتماعيه وبه حركات تملك من الادوات
العسكريه ما يمكن ان يعني تؤدي الى
احتكارها او سيطرتها على مناطق بشكل كبير
وبشكل محدد هذا هو السيناريو الاخطر هذا
هو الشبح الذي يمكن ان يخلق مصر كثيرا
ويجب ان تستعد له لانه ليس ببعيد السودان
عبر عشرات السنين يواجه حروبا اهليه
واشتباكاتهم بين حركات المسلحه والجيش
السوداني وما الى ذلك لكن لم يشهد على
الاطلاق معارك داخل الخرطوم داخل العاصمه
هذه هي المفارقه الكبيره وهذا هو
الفارق النوعي ما بين ما يحدث الان وبين
ما حدث قبل ذلك في اقاليم سواء كان في
دارفور او في جنوب السودان هذه
السيناريوهات
الخطيره والتي يمكن ان تؤثر على المصالح
المصريه بشكل كبير تفرض على القياده
المصريه التدخل وفتح قنوات متعدده الاستاذ
محمد
ما هي خيارات القاهره ما هي خيارات مصر
ومعروف انه السودان هو حديقه خلفيه لامنها
القومي
لا انا لا اميل الى الخيار العسكري كما
يردد البعض وكما حاول البعض تشويه صوره
مصر في هذه المساله مصر معروف انها لديها
شعار محدد وواضح فيما يتعلق بعدم التدخل
في امور دول اخرى وفي السودان بشكل خاص
هذا هذه مساله في تقديره مستبعده تماما لم
تتدخل مصر في ليبيا وهي جاره ايضا وكانت
الامور فيها اكثر بساطه مما هو حاصل الان
في السودان اعتقد ان يعني تدخل مصر في
السودان هو نوع من انواع التوريد نوع من
انواع عدم القدره على تحديد موعد محدد
لمساله العوده وبالتالي هذا سيناريو
مستبعد من من تفكير يعني اي محلل سياسي
يراقب المعطيات المصريه في التصرف مع مثل
هذه الامور يستبعده تماما لكن ايضا في
المقابل هناك تحركات تقوم بها باسرع مستوى
الدبلوماسي وعلى المستوى المخابرات متعدده
لوضع حل سريع لوقف اطلاق النار لان
المساله يعني اذا استمرت اياما اخرى سوف
تكون مصر المتضرر الاكبر بالفعل من مما
يحدث في السودان
من القاهره مدير تحرير المدير تحرير في
جريده الاهرام والمختصرفي محمد ابو الفضل
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
وهذه اعزائي المشاهدين مقاطع فيديو مصوره
يقال انها لسيطره القوات البريه في الجيش
السوداني على محيط القياده العامه او على
مقر القياده العامه نتابع الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
من قوات الدعم السريع وقالت فيها قوات
الدعم السريعه انها سيطرت على مبنى الهيئه
العامه للاذاعه والتلفزيون اذا هذه مقاطع
فيديو من قوات الدعم السريع تقول في اقوات
الدعم السريع انها سيطرت على مبنى الهيئه
العامه للادعوه التلفزيون هذا مع الاشاره
اعزائي المشاهدين الى ان مبنى البث ما زال
تحت سيطره الجيش السوداني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معناتها
بالشارع كلها
مبروك
[موسيقى]
بالطبع تغطيتنا للتطورات لدراماتيكيه في
السودان مستمره ولكن الان اعزائي
المشاهدين الى مجموعه من الاخبار حول
العالم والبدايه مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الذي سعى الى تهدئه اي خلاف بين الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها بشان تشريب الوثائق
السريه من الولايات المتحده وقال اوستن
خلال اجتماع لوزراء الدفاع عقد في قاعده
ايرامشتاين الجويه في المانيا انه ياخذ
هذه القضيه على محمل الجد وسيواصل العمل
عن كثب مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده ومع
شركائها
اعلم ان الكثير منكم كان يتابع التقارير
قضيه تسريب الوثائق الحساسه الامريكيه
دققت في هذه القضيه بشكل جاد ونعمل عن قرب
مع الحلفاء والشركاء الذين اكدوا لنا
دعمهم الكامل لن تسمح باي محاولات للنيل
من وحدتنا
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان الله
ان الاجراءات والخطابات الاخيره من
اوكرانيا تظهر ان روسيا بحاجه الى مواصله
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في تلك البلاد
مؤكده ان العمليه ستستمر حتى تكتمل
اهدافها المعلنه والمتمثله في نزع السلاح
والقضاء على التهديدات للامن القومي
الروسي
قال الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي يانص
ان مستقبل اوكرانيا سيكون عبر انضمامها
الى حلف شمال الاطلسي مؤكدا ان حلفاء
النيتو اجمعوا على ان تصبح اوكرانيا عضوا
في هذا الحلف
قلت في كييف بالامس ان مستقبل اوكرانيا
يكمن في الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
وكل حلفاء النيتو قد اجمعوا على ان تصبح
اوكرانيا عضوا في النيتو لكن يجب ان نركز
الان على كيفيه ضمان انتصار اوكرانيا في
الحرب ضد روسيا
حفصه الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا على
الانسحاب من بخ مت منذ يناير الماضي لعدم
قدرته على السيطره على وضع المدينه بحسب
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه وذلك نقلا عن
وثائق البينتاجون المسربه ووفق الصحيفه
اقدم اطواشنطن على هذه النصيحه بعد ان
كانت تقدم الروسي ثابتا منذ نوفمبر وحينما
لم تستجب اوكرانيا لتلك التحذيرات وقررت
البقاء اقترحت الوثائق السريه ان يتم
التخطيط لاحباط الروح المعنويه الروسيه
موصيه بشن هجمات بذخيره تقليديه محسنه ذات
استخدام المزدوج ومزيج من قصف المدفعيه
وصواريخ ارض جو
افاد مراسل العربيه ان بولندا ودول
البلطيق تضغط من اجل استيراد الذخيره
والصواريخ من كوريا الجنوبيه لدعم
اوكرانيا ومن جهه اكد مصدر دبلوماسيون
اوروبي ان الدعم الاجنبي لاوكرانيا يثير
حفيظه فرنسا التي تعترض على استيراد
الذخيره والصواريخ من خارج اوروبا لدعم
اوكرانيا مشيرا الى ان فرنسا تقول انه يجب
الاعتماد على صناعات الذخيره
والصواريخ الاوروبيه لدعم
مع استمرار الخلافات بين واشنطن وبيكين
حذرت الخارجيه الصينيه من التدخل في
شؤونها وفي علاقاتها الدوليه وقالت
الخارجيه الصينيه ان الشراكه بين بيكين
وموسكو ليس لها حدود
وتاتي التصريحات الصينيه ردا على وزيره
الخزانه الامريكيه جاني التي اتهمت الصين
بانها ليست جاده بشان انهاء الحرب في
اوكرانيا
هذا وحذر وزير الخارجيه الصيني من ان
انتقاد الصين بشان تايوان سيكون له عواقب
وخيمه وقال تشين ان هناك خطابات تتحدث عن
تغيير الوضع الراهن من جانب واحد عبر مضيق
تايوان من خلال القوه او الاكراه وتعطيل
السلام والاستقرار عبر المضيق مشيرا الى
ان مثل هذه الادعاءات تتعارض مع طبيعه
العلاقات الدوليه ولها عواقب خطيره
[موسيقى]
بالطبع اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه
لمجريات التطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان
متواصله بعد قليل يصحاب يقوم الزميل
ابراهيم بدر في ساعه من هذه التغطيه من
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات